let's talk about what's going on in
california though this is funny yeah
ladies and gentlemen i give you our our
um
what's um
okay who was the the guy who wrote the
story about uh the clown comes out from
behind the stage and tries to warn the
audience there's a fire some philosopher
i don't know
kindergarten okay yeah yeah so here's
the story first larry elder brushes off
la times column that called him the
black face of white supremacy
okay okay uh clayton bigsby the dave
chappelle sketch is not real these
people are insane but this is a really
good example of the the kicker guard
story i think it's kierker of the the
the clown
he comes out from backstage where the
fire a fire has broken out and he starts
frantically waving to the audience
there's a fire in the back everyone get
out they'll start laughing
laughing with joy and he the clown gets
frustrated and tries desperately to tell
them but the more energetic he gets to
warn about the fire that's actually
burning on the theater the more they
laugh
and then he says kyrgat says i imagine
that's you know how the world will end
you know that people you know what i
forgot exactly what he said but the
people are going to be laughing not
realizing what's going on around them
when when okay look larry elder might
win this one and i think that would be
amazing he's a libertarian guy he's he's
a smart fella and they're pulling out
every stop imaginable to try and block
larry elder from winning in california
here's what you need to understand
gavin newsom will get recalled if people
vote to recall
if they don't vote for here's my i could
be wrong but my understanding is
if you walk in and say recall and walk
out
he gets recalled
you don't need necessarily to vote for
someone to replace him yeah that's
exactly right yeah get rid of them
well you lived under uh under newsom
right yeah i did how was that
i mean
we i kind of lived in a renegade county
orange county isn't isn't quite like la
or san diego certainly not like san
francisco so uh orange county has a long
history of uh fighting back against um
sort of big metropolises like l.a i mean
orange county used to be a part of la
and then there was a big fight and then
they broke off and they were just like
we don't we don't want to have what you
guys are doing in l.a so um i had that
benefit so but at the same time i mean
yeah the lock down was crazy i mean it
was it was total and it was complete and
everybody had to wear a mask i'll never
forget the first time i encountered one
of my friends on the sidewalk and she
goes the cdc said we can take our masks
off is the first time i've seen her
without a mask on wow such a sweet lady
but you know i mean i was just like
really you need the cdc to tell you that
outside
when there's you know it's 72 degrees
every day and you can enjoy you know the
air and everything so i mean but yeah
that's the mentality out there but based
on you living under him you think recall
yeah
i talked to some political strategists
that have uh
that not only have been working
california politics for decades but they
are actually actively working with some
of the people that are hoping to replace
newsome as governor
uh oh yeah yeah republicans uh yeah yeah
pretty much all of them um and uh they
this was probably four months ago and
they said
make do not misunderstand this gavin
newsom will not lose he will not be
recalled he will not be replaced period
there's just but this is back when there
was just a bunch of like you know kind
of half recognizable clown names you
know they were throwing their hat there
was one guy that was going around
california with a bear remember this
no oh yeah he would he did like a couple
uh speeches with a with a bear but the
bear wasn't even a california bear so
that was really embarrassing um uh so
that was the worst of it yeah yeah yeah
and the bear was like kind of bear the
bear was like you know looking licking
itself while he was trying to give a
speech it was it was you know that's
great so when you saw when you see stuff
like that you're just like okay i mean
but the political strategist that i
talked to would say things like no no
you have to understand that gavin newsom
and they spoke off the record of course
they didn't want me to print what they
said they said newsom is such a ruthless
conniving politician that he he is
absolutely not going to let anybody take
over for him as governor
larry elder is changing that and you can
see that he's changing that by the by
the total derangement that you're seeing
on the la times i mean i saw a collage
the other day it was like it was like
six titles they're just like flinging
every piece of pasta that they possibly
can at the wall to see what sticks on
this guy and it's not working because
larry elder makes sense he's a sane guy
i know but but like
who in their right mind would call a
black man the face of white supremacy
i don't know well what is wrong with
these people i don't think this is the
world they're sick they're sick
sometimes i feel like the clown running
out on the stage and going
and everyone's just laughing like
i'm
yeah yeah i wonder about that because i
i try and have like levity in my life
and be kind of a jokester and not take
things too seriously but i wonder if if
a result of that is that people aren't
going to take me seriously when i'm
screaming about
the fall
the danger that we're looking at i don't
know
let me let me let me read a little bit
read a little bit of this they say the
l.a times published a column on friday
titled larry elder is the black face of
white supremacy you've been warned
which accuses the republican of using
overly simplistic arguments that
whitewash the complex problems that come
along with being black in america la
times columnist erica d smith said elder
uses taunting and toddler-like
name-calling of his ideological enemies
before belittling the gubernatorial
candidate with her own insults
i've learned that it's often best just
to ignore people like elder people who
are as my dad just say skin folk but not
kinfolk she wrote before attempting to
insult elder as a trump fanboy dangerous
a troll and implied he doesn't
understand critical race theory his
candidacy feels personal like an insult
to blackness the times columnist wrote
fox news sean hannity called the column
disgusting and invited elder to respond
to it directly
quote i am genuinely friend-of-friend
sorry that you have to go through
something as evil horrific and racist as
that and he said
however elder who leads the pack of
republican candidates looking to replace
california given uh governor gavin
newsom wasn't surprised quote i
anticipated that would happen this is
why a lot of people don't go into
politics because of the politics of
personal destruction it's not the first
time the la times attacked me there was
another writer who all but called me a
black david duke oh they're confused wow
they're scared to death
that is definitely true look at this
libs of tick tock hold this up this is
great let's pull this up i love them
they're terrified of larry elder
all of these uh oh come on are you gonna
you're gonna give me the business i
can't pull up the photo anymore yeah i
don't think it's gonna let me okay well
we can read some of it larry elder the
black face of white supremacy larry
elder talks a lot too bad you can't
believe anything he says larry elder
bashes the media offers no solutions
remind you of an ex-president no wow i
see how many people in california are
like ooh that's good you know i do like
trump
what is this oh yes state officials open
investigation into whether larry elder
failed to disclose income sources
convenient jeez
if larry elder is elected life will get
harder for black and latino californians
amazing that's my other favorite one
right there that's a good one yeah
they're really scared of this guy he's
leading the pack yeah he is and
this was not supposed to happen that's
what's so funny is that like it was just
guaranteed that this recall effort won't
work they are branding it so hard as
right-wing republican
it's a right wing recall vote no on the
republican recall i mean they are so
desperate to brand it that way and
people just still aren't having it i
know democrats in california that died
in the wool democrats voted for biden
they vote for him again they said i'm
still voting yes on a recall oh yeah do
you think the recall's going to go
through i do really i do it's neck and
neck though i i really want to be white
pilled on this i really like it i mean i
i it's going to happen yeah got to
believe you're going to say something so
yeah did you see the interview that
gavin newsom gave where he was like
maniacal he looked like what's his name
bateman yeah when he was mayor of san
francisco yeah yeah that was great the
reporter keeps trying to ask him like
logical questions about all the problems
that he's caused and he just he's
cackling and he he's he cuts off the
first uh question from the reporter i
believe and he just like starts naming
like numbers and stuff
total patrick bateman yeah yeah crazy
person american psycho he owns it he
owns the american psycho thing
yeah he does
well you know when i saw him defying his
own covet mandates i was like despite
get him out yeah so i've see i've seen
the polling but it's i i gotta say i
guess i'm not entirely surprised that
some democrats democrats are like get
rid of the guy now here's where it gets
really funny
from newsweek well it's from newsweek
but it's quoting 5 38 nate silver calls
democratic strategy to leave newsome
recall candidate line blank
self-destructive
if newsom gets recalled the democrats
have offered up no one is that is that
what's going on so the only option you
have as a republican so larry elder's
gonna win
wow i hadn't even thought about that
scenario that's crazy well so here's
what they say 538 founder nate silver
said monday the strategy california
democrats are pursuing heading into next
month's gubernatorial recall election is
self-destructive as sitting governor
gavin newsom faces the possibility that
he could be voted out of office the
democratic party is encouraging
californians to vote against removing
newsome from office but to refrain from
selecting amongst the 46 replacement
candidates who appear in the recall
ballot okay so is are there there got to
be some democrats newsom's campaign has
made similar recommendations in recent
weeks on monday silva responded to a
tweet posted by a political reporter who
suggested the strategy was
self-interested it's self-destructive
more than self-interested
pre uh pretty decent chances gets
recalled democrats could potentially
keep the seat if they urge their voters
to consolidate behind an alternative
democrat but instead they're telling
them not to vote on the replacement
dude larry elder for governor is going
to be so amazing that would be amazing i
want to see that in california yeah you
know because you you've heard like what
he's going to do
when he keeps saying when he becomes
governor is that he's just going to
issue all these executive orders to like
just basically cancel out a lot of these
democrat policies that have gone through
these super majorities unchecked that
have basically bankrupted the whole
state caused so much homelessness uh
people can't afford to live you know i
mean and he's just gonna put a stop to
all those policies in day one according
to him you know but we'll see i think
he'd do it
he would do it i don't know how
effective it would be yeah that's that's
that's the big risk right when when
trump got in office he made the mistake
of thinking he could he could pull the
trigger and then we see clearly he was
obstructed every you know across the
board so there's a lot of work to be
done the the the tendrils of the
corruption run deep
and you you we have a uh we have a um a
medium-sized animal trap for next to our
chicken coop because we you know we have
a fox that lurks around and we don't
want them to get in the chickens right
so we set this trap up well over time
the the uh grass and everything grew up
into it
and have now locked it in place it grew
all around it and i used it like rip it
out see that's what happens with the
these these super majorities
this is what happens in dc the swamp
grows deep the roots get in there thick
and then it's really hard to pull it out
so larry elder could get in
but you know is it going to be able to
effectively weed another metaphor is
like if you get black mold toxicity if
you breathe it in what happens is the
mold goes into your system then it
diffuses evenly throughout your entire
system so you just have small particles
of mold in your entire system it's
really hard to clean out similar of how
politics can corrupt and influence the
society it's not just something we can
pull out it's permeated the entire
system it needs to be purged slowly
at the right medicine i want to make
sure i understand that so are you
calling larry alder the black mold of
white supremacy yes the black mole of
white supremacy that's okay all right
okay got it got it no you're saying the
corruption is infecting your body and
you can't get it out the corruption is
the black mold of whites
because like if it spreads around your
house you could scrub the room where you
see it but not realize there's tiny
particles already moved somewhere else
that grow again and it's like really
weeding it out thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you